كشف رئيس جهاز الشباك الاسرائيلي ان جهاز
الامن الداخلي الاسرائيلي حصل على معلومات
عن خليه للمقاومه في جنين كانت تعمل على
تطوير صواريخ اضافنا الجهاز تمكن من القاء
القبض على عناصر الخليه حسب زعمه واضاف ان
خليه اخرى في رام الله تم كشفها وكانت
تتدرب على تسيير طائرات دون طيار لتنفيذ
عمليات في العمق الاسرائيلي
في الاسابيع الاخيره قمنا بتصفيه خليه في
جنين كانت تعمل على انتاج صواريخ لاطلاقها
من داخل الضفه الغربيه باتجاه اسرائيل
وهذه سابقه خطيره وبالتالي وبناء على
معلومات تلقيناها كشفنا الخليه وتم القاء
القبض على افرادها وقد اعترفوا لا نريد
تحويل العفوله وشكيد لمواقع تتعرض لاطلاق
صواريخ واعتقلنا ايضا في رام الله خلايا
كانت تحاول استخدام المسيرات ضد
اسرائيليين وتم احباط العمليه